I think our daughters are friends I
think it makes us friends I'm hunter I'm
Lisa that's my Julie Mitchell Ken's hero
I can't believe it's prom you're so
grown-up
can you hug my daughter anymore without
feeling her boobs just high-fives no
[Music]
Julie left your laptop open because are
stepping on our kids oh we don't
understand what they're saying so it's
not snooping and teenage emoji eggplants
are dicks all emojis have a secret
meaning so like trees are we and this
thing is your screen so she's gonna get
Rosita kiss and then touch his dick
eggplant come on drool coming out this -
that's just stand down they're planning
on losing their virginity on prom night
maybe that's not sex through I'm gonna
stop them I'm in let's [ __ ] block those
[ __ ]
this is our last big night together this
Patrick's gonna mix not even more
process you're gonna wake WWV didi what
would Vin Diesel do
[Music]
in terms of prices parents are no
simians joke
this is so messed up your dad try to
stop you when you wanted to lose your
virginity was too busy high-fiving me
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about a little chugging contests
bringing that westward but Chuck
you got this dog no I'm tagging out
you're in what put a baby everything's
looser down there a baby out of my back
on the count of three one I'm tripping
so hard I just had a vision
my dad was chugging beer it was [ __ ]
I can't do any more
[Music]
you